"Leaving Coldzera in a 1 on 4. There's the first, looking for a second he connects it. Oh and he gets a third as well."
"Surely he's not going to pull this off. Oh Coldzera, the man, the myth, the beast."
Coldzera. The man, the myth, the motherf***ing beast.
I don’t care if your name is Niko, s1mple, or Colin for theScore esports -- you do not want to be go toe-to-toe with this guy in a server.
He has impeccable game sense, incredible aim, and yes an ice COLD demeanor in and outside of the game.
"Hey guys well played I was rooting for y'all."
"You showed us up dude don't worry."
This week on Best of, we’re looking at the absolute finest from the coolest man in Counter-Strike, Coldzera.
Now, where do you start when you’re talking about a man, who is arguably the best in the world at what he does?
Well, why don’t we take a look at his early days in Luminosity.
"Now of course we are looking at Luminosity. Their roster for you: FalleN, steel, fer, boltz and the new man Coldzera."
"As he's gonna be kind of that new factor for them. Intrigued to see how much he could do."
"I think the best player in the world is..."
"Coldzera."
(Casting)
"Worlds best player? uhh i gotta say, Coldzera."
"Coldzera."
(Casting)
"Uhh the best way to describe Coldzera, I think he is the most consistent player in the world, I think he is the rock of the team he plays for."
"No."
"Not again, I've got to end this thing before it begins."
(Casting)
You guys already know this, but In CS:GO some people are AWPers, some are riflers, and some can just do it all.
Put any weapon into Coldzera’s hands and this man makes incredible things happen. With or without the rest of his team.
(Casting)
"Crisp, clean lock boys, doesn't get more horsesh*t than that."
You know, some say the mark of a true great is a high level of performance when it matters the most.
And over the years Coldzera has shown us that he truly has ice in his veins.
Whether it’s an online league or a Major grand final on LAN, Cold doesn’t choke.
(Casting)
"The Iceman cometh."
Well guys, that was the Best of Coldzera. Now I almost didn’t bring this up, but for my money, Cold is the best CS player in the world.
He’s got the consistency, he’s got the highlight reel,  and he’s got the championship rings, so to speak, to back it all up.
Now, if you’re in the comment section talking about NiKo or s1mple, or even my boy Guardian, I respect it, but don’t @ me.
"Ohh!"